in march last year this place of worship
became a scene of terror now it's hoped
it can be a symbol of change
as muslim leaders and survivors gathered
at the al-noor mosque
to discuss the findings of an
independent report into a terrorist
attack
we've seen the apology from the prime
minister from the police from
the intelligence service which is
something good we started from there
and now we are looking for the change
after hundreds of interviews and written
submissions the commission of inquiries
findings were made public
it found that intelligence and security
agencies were too focused on
islamic extremists and didn't pay enough
attention to others
including white supremacists like
brenton tarrant who carried out the
attack
on two mosques in christchurch and it
found police failed to meet required
standards
when they issued him a firearms licence
without proper character references
or background checks while the
commission made no findings that these
issues would have stopped the attack
these were failings nonetheless and for
that
on behalf of the government i apologize
tarant was among those interviewed for
the report but his comments have been
permanently suppressed
to avoid them being used by others as
motivation to carry out similar attacks
some in the muslim community are
welcoming the recommendations
others are saying the report doesn't go
far enough and there is skepticism about
any
real change because many say they've
been raising some of the same concerns
outlined in the report for years and no
one listened
and no one acted until a gunman entered
the mosques and killed 51 people
the government has accepted in principle
all 44 recommendations
which include strengthening laws on hate
crimes of which many muslims say they've
been victims
the commission's ultimate finding was
that nothing could have been done to
stop the attacks
many in the community that was targeted
by the gunman disagree
saying if they had only been listened to
a long time ago
the lives of 51 people could have been
saved
wayne hey al jazeera christchurch